[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
if we ever needed an anti-war movement
it's obviously now Trump's hyper
aggressive foreign policy faces little
resistance in the mainstream media in
fact numerous liberal news outlets
function as a cheering section for the
president
where is the moral outrage
[Music]
crosstalking the anti-war resistance I'm
joined by my guest Medea Benjamin in
Washington she is an author as well as
co-founder of code pink also in
Washington we have Walter melodic he's
an answer coalition organizer and in
Romania we cross Takei brand Jacobsen he
is the director of the department of
peace operations of the Romanian Peace
Institute
all right crosstalk rules in effect that
means he can jump in in any time you
want and I always appreciate modeun let
me go to you first I mean you and I
probably remember quite well in 2003 the
illegal invasion of Iraq but the the
anti-war movement was vast it was strong
it was loud it was all across Europe it
was in the UK it was a very strong in
the United States even though the media
didn't like to cover it
there was a real anti-war movement now
speed up to 2019 under the Trump
administration the we hear we hear calls
for war and violence an invasion of
Venezuela of Iran we have the United
States supplying lethal weapons to
Ukraine we have the United States going
through the South China Sea as
remarkably in the middle of trade
negotiations here we have a hyper
aggressive foreign policy but where is
the anti-war movement other than places
like this and people like yourselves go
ahead Madea in Washington unfortunately
I think people are so consumed by
domestic issues and there are so many
important issues and the mainstream
media in this country is super hyper
focused on domestic issues and on
partisan issues and there is very little
coverage of what's going on in the world
I think for the most part people are
unaware of all of these global wars that
are still going on two decades
afterwards and the new threats that are
happening so we have an uneducated
public and those who are educated in
terms of being active and wanting to get
involved tend to be involved in issues
related to the environment to the
terrible issues of racism the issues
around things like homophobia
Islamophobia and partisan politics okay
but Walter is the lack of knowledge the
ignorance and intentional
ploy by the media because when it comes
to these foreign policy issues I'm
thinking of MSNBC CN and I mean in some
degree with Fox obviously they're just
stenographers for power I thought they
said they would never do that again that
they had learned their lesson from the
illegal invasion of Iraq but they
haven't learned their lesson at all this
matter of fact it's even far worse now
because as a result of 2003 a lot of
people were essentially blacklisted
banned from the airwaves and they're
still banned because they talk about
obvious things like breaking of
international law I mean it's if the
American people knew I think that they
might think differently but they don't
know Walter oh absolutely I agree with
you I mean I think that it has to be
intentional I mean how else could there
be an absolute blackout on on all the
most important things going on in the
world practically either either a
blackout in the sense that it's not
covered or in the sense that it's just
distorted to such a great extent that
people really have no idea what the what
the reality of this situation is and
most importantly for protests what the
role of the United States government is
and sowing discord and chaos and
suffering all around the world whether
that's in Yemen the invasion of Libya
and in ongoing chaos in Libya in Syria
in Venezuela the suffering imposed as a
consequence of sanctions on Iran I think
that you know the mainstream media the
corporate media had deserves much of the
blame but I think it's facilitated by a
shift in tactics that the pentagon war
machine has undergone since the 2003
invasion of Iraq which of course
involved large numbers of troops on the
ground quote-unquote boots on the ground
where are hundreds of thousands of US
soldiers were stationed in Iraq were
occupying the country were patrolling
the streets every day and as a
consequence of course the Iraqi people
didn't like being occupied and so there
was a resistance movement that formed
and so thousands of US troops were
killed many thousands more suffered
life-altering wounds serious serious
injuries and that made the war you know
more more real for people and made it in
other words harder to conceal by the
mainstream media but when I think we saw
especially with the Obama administration
as it turned towards things like drone
war
turn towards you know the the heavy use
of special operations forces things that
can be more easily concealed that's very
interesting what let's go to Romania let
me just add to that proxy wars exactly
here okay right now the the the European
Union and NATO countries that are part
of the European Union they're getting a
lot of pressure from the Trump
administration to fall in line as
regards to Iran and there seems to be
some resistance pockets of resistance
but at the end of the day they're gonna
have to follow the United States because
the United States has applied so much
pressure here I mean it would be very
helpful if the Europeans could it be a
little bit you know grow a little bit
more of a spine if I can say it that way
and say that you know they don't have a
problem Iran is a not a threat to them
it's certainly not an existential threat
to the United States in any way at all
but the Europeans does tend to just fall
in line and I think I find that really
disappointing go ahead in Romania I
think part of the challenge that we face
in Europe is that Europe itself is not
United that's right across the European
Union you can see recently with or Vons
visit in Trump and you have the regime
in Washington actively cultivating
right-wing and authoritarian regimes
across much of Europe so any attempt to
bring about a consensus amongst European
nations as to their approaches on Iran
or many other foreign policy issues is
increasingly difficult and challenged I
think in comparing to the anti-war
movement that we saw before the invasion
of Iraq in 2003 the context was very
different that was a campaign which had
been built up over multiple years and
also sanctions that had been imposed
onion talk since the first Gulf War and
in that time you'd had the development
of a substantial network of an anti-war
movement all across the United States
you'd had the build-up of opposition to
the sanctions on Iraq across Europe and
internationally and you also had many
within governments in Europe who were
strongly opposed to what they saw was an
invasion that would worsen security and
bring about many negative consequences
in the region as it did our challenge
today is that the camp
to escalate crises are constant and much
faster so there's a shorter time to
build up broad-based movements in
response to them these are often
situations or areas which many citizens
don't have that much information they
don't feel the connection they're not as
aware of what's happening there and I
think also whether politicians are
citizens many people have been saturated
over the last more than 15 years of
continual war and aggression not only by
the United States but by the United
States by Russia Saudi Arabia many
countries have been pursuing very
aggressive militarist policies on a
global scale okay I mentioned earlier in
the program I mean I would I'm sure you
remember when when Trump ordered the
missile attack against Assyria very
early in his administration and you know
the way I look at it Russia Gate has
always been just a hoax a myth it was it
worked for ratings for a while ask
Rachel Maddow
but when Trump egregiously broke
international law in attacking Syria for
and now we know that there was no
chemical attack it was fake it was
staged here but the Liberals went to his
side calling him presidential I mean
it's it defies logic to me because you
you know you you're they were chasing
this hoax for over two years they're
still doing it there's nothing there but
that bombing campaign was illegal we did
see it but they were called beautiful
missiles what's happened to the left go
ahead in Washington well I wouldn't call
that the left I would say the left was
not calling the beautiful missiles but I
do agree NBC NBC NBC is the left I think
you would agree with that
MSNBC's left well I call them Pro
Democrats and I don't really think of
them as the left but in any case I agree
with your premise which is stating that
the Democrats tend to cheer on the
Republicans when they're are doing
something that is totally illegal but it
is fighting bombing supporting military
industrial complex I do want to say
though we have had something
extraordinary in this year which is the
Democrats and some Republicans coming
together to try to oppose the u.s.
support for the Saudi bombing in Yemen
and that actually passed in both the
House and the Senate the first time
using the War Powers Act and a lot of
support from grassroots communities to
make that happen
unfortunately Trump vetoed that and we
didn't have the votes to override it but
it is a good example of forcing enough
Republicans to join with Democrats to
say no to support for an illegal war
Cayenne remaining I saw you agreeing go
ahead jump in well I think the last
point that maybe I just mentioned is
critical the increasing opposition to
the war in Yemen and the role that not
only the United States but European
countries are playing on it playing in
it and we've seen an alliance between
many governments and citizens working to
block weapon sales to Saudi Arabia
working to raise awareness about it so I
think there is actually a peace movement
that is vibrant that is present on your
other point with regards to coverage
this is I wouldn't necessarily call
MSNBC left either they're very central
establishment but we've seen this in the
first Gulf War we've seen this in the
second Gulf War you have an almost
homogenous approach across media in
celebrating congratulating and
cheerleading military aggression abroad
and that's not unique to the United
States we see this across most countries
and most media what is necessary in
terms of campaigning and engaging as
organizations and citizens is this
constant effort to reach out to raise
people's awareness and I think what's
critical to date to D legitimize war as
an approach to addressing conflicts
internationally if you look at any of
the major large the alarm' conflicts
over the last 20 years they have almost
all ended in strategic failure it was
actually the Canadian general to signal
the commander of all UN forces in Rwanda
after romeo Dallaire who said quite
explicitly war and the military cannot
bring peace they never had they never
will
at the same time we've seen the
incredible development in the last 20
years of the field of peacebuilding
international organizations and agencies
working on the ground and communities
affected by violent conflict very
effectively engaged in prevention very
effectively engaged working in mediation
and peace processes and for 30 years I
have to jump in here we're gonna go to a
short break and after that short break
we'll continue our discussion on the
anti-war resistance State with our team
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
to remind you were discussing the
anti-war resistance
[Music]
okay let's go back to Walter in
Washington if we all remember when
Barack Obama made his ran for president
for the first time in 2008 he I would
call him a moderate anti-war or moderate
Pro peace candidate and it was appealing
to people and we had speed up to 2016
and Donald Trump was doubting NATO
and doubting the the necessity of
foreign wars in the Middle East a
necessity to have infrastructure at home
and both presidents in office were
bentham to back into the establishment
ways I mean Walter what happens because
I would say Donald Trump in dangers his
re-election with a lot of people that
voted form just on the issue of
non-interference in Foreign Wars and I
mean those were veterans families of
veterans maybe it was a sliver of the
electorate but it might have been
important what happens to these
presidents that run on these platforms
but when they get in power and all
changes go ahead Walter well I
absolutely agree that it's a very
important issue I think it's an
underrated issue in terms of public
opinion and electoral significance
Barack Obama I think not only was able
to defeat McCain on the basis of his
being you know Cena's sort of more
opposed to the Iraq war I think that was
also central to his primary election
victory over Hillary Clinton within the
Democratic Party and yeah absolutely I
mean I think that there are some people
who may have voted for Trump on the
issues of war and peace or I think more
likely just sort of stayed home you know
people who would have maybe otherwise
voted for a Democrat but stayed at home
because they were so disgusted by the
endless wars that are going on all
around the world waged by the United
States look I mean I think the United
States is is fundamentally acts as an
empire when it comes to its relations
with the rest of the world I mean
there's no sense of cooperation there's
no sense of mutual respect I mean
there's just sort of dictates given by
Washington and and that's created you
know a system that is much more powerful
than I think the individual person
sitting in the Oval Office that includes
of course the the Millett
industrial complex you know the big
weapons manufacturer is Boeing Lockheed
Martin all the people who make billions
and billions tens of billions of dollars
off of this perpetual warfare state I
think it actually goes deeper than that
I think that the big banks and
corporations in the United States you
know they need access to markets they
need access to labor forces to exploit
and the sort of rules of the game
internationally as they like to refer to
it when it comes to trade and other
economic policies you know the the
Washington Consensus is something that
they value very heavily so the the
institutional weight of all of those
interests all those very very powerful
people in institutions I think can
basically overwhelm any individual
sitting in the White House but but to go
back to our conversation about the
anti-war movement I think that it can
also be said that a mass movement can
overwhelm those very powerful entrenched
interests and fight back in a very
effective way yeah Media go ahead jump
in go ahead go ahead I just wanted to
add a piece to what Walter was talking
about and that's small interest groups
that are powerful lobbies in the United
States that help to shape policies on
particular issues for example the groups
like a PAC or the Christian Zionists
that helped to keep the u.s.
relationship very tight with the Israeli
government or groups right now that
we're seeing a venezuelan Americans when
the Trump administration wants to win
Florida in the upcoming elections and
there's about 200,000 of them could that
could really tip the vote or we have
some conservative irani American groups
that for them the most important thing
is US policy around Iran so those small
groups they don't reflect public opinion
in general but they have an outsized
influence yeah okay but you know public
opinion but public opinion is
manufactured I mean if you look at we
could take the example of Venezuela oh
it's a it's a socialist country that's
why the United States has to intervene I
mean that's a ridiculous claim to make
but that's pedals all of the time and
it's and it's bipartisan
as well I mean the coverage of Benes
whele is just appalling it takes someone
like max Blumenthal from the gray zone
to go down there with a camera crew and
just absolutely humiliate the mainstream
media they're reporting fictions okay
Venezuela has a lot of problems there's
no denying it but that's not a
justification to invade the country
violate the country's sovereignty break
international law but those just those
issues that I just mentioned they're
never mentioned in the mainstream no
wonder people don't understand what's
going on because that the the the
narrative is manufactured in a way that
is so self-serving to power that why
wouldn't the American people Europeans
say oh this gueto guy sounds all right
though he's completely an invention of
Washington and the media goes along with
it that's why we have permanent war go
ahead in Romania I think when you're
speaking about manufacturing opinion and
consent one of the things that we see
though is while you have that constant
narrative coming from across the breadth
of media most people don't necessarily
buy into it or agree with it you look at
it polls in the United States or across
Europe the overwhelming majority of
citizens is the average citizen in our
countries are sick and tired of war
they're opposed to Wars they're opposed
to invasions but the problem is on the
one hand you have this almost
homogeneous narrative coming from across
different media and you have the lack of
making visible any practical
alternatives so just because the news
stations are constantly broadcasting how
evil this regime or that regime is
whichever angle they're coming from it
doesn't mean that the majority of
citizens actually buy into it our
challenge is that because of the
constant bombardment of war that we have
faced in the concept bombardment of
crisis and challenges in people's lives
from the invasions of Iraq Afghanistan
September 11th the financial crisis
brexit this constant messaging of crisis
and stress I think the average citizen
when you speak to them doesn't see
practically what can I do to bring about
change so you may have some support for
candidates who say they're opposed
toward they're opposed to foreign
interventions and then those promises
are broken
which most citizens are very used to
from political leadership here
unfortunately but I think we need to be
working at this point in history drawing
lessons from the civil rights movement
the environmental movement the women's
movement to really be building a
broad-based
alliance of citizens and people from all
different backgrounds recognizing the
incredible destructiveness of war we can
see what has resulted across the Middle
East and North Africa following the
invasions of Iraq the war in Syria and
Libya and Yemen and also dealing with
this myth that has been perpetuated for
hundreds of years that war is good for
business war is good for weapons
industry which is been growing
dramatically for mercenary corporations
which is smuggling black market economy
but the overwhelming majority of
businesses and industry and workers and
citizens alike suffer from war so
there's a opportunity now at this moment
in history to actually be building a
broad-based movement and also engaging
with governments around the world to
find practical and effective
alternatives and to D legitimize the
drive and the momentum for war whether
that's coming from a Democrat or a
Republican president whether it's coming
from the United States Turkey Saudi
Arabia Russia or what have you to be
engaging with citizens who are tired of
this constant military engagement
constantly yeah but kind you know let me
go to Walter you will you have will you
have a candidate Tulsi Gabbard you know
she really shows her cards and it's
really quite amazing how they tried to
shut her down I mean she doesn't even
tell the graph where she's going to
speak because there's she's hounded to
death on on on Twitter and everywhere
else because she challenges the the is
the status quo and and you know what
I've seen her speak many times albeit on
YouTube she speaks very authoritative ly
and very intelligent she knows exactly
what she's talking about
she knows a lot of nuance about foreign
policy and she speaks actually quite
presidential in my opinion compared to
all the other phonies that are running
for president on the Democratic Party's
side oh and I'd like to also Makai
talked about deal agenda my's
how do we deal Ajith amaizing we're a
former executive Boeing will be now
become the secretary of defense Shanahan
a fascinating article right now in the
American conservative it'll Italy it's
so galling and so obvious that this is a
revolving door here but you that's never
mentioned in the mainstream Walter go
ahead I mean it's it's really remarkable
a remarkable testament to the power of
the mainstream media that's somebody
like bado
O'Rourke you know this just completely
vapid failure it's considered to be a
serious presidential contender but Tulsi
Gabbard is you know completely blocked
from from the airwaves and as a
consequence I think polling very low not
because of you know the presentation
that she gives or you know the ideas
that she promotes but but I think
because the corporate media has
basically decided that that's out of
bounds that's not allowed within the
very narrow constraints of US political
discourse so the the point about you
know the D legitimacy of the system I
mean I think this this is sort of one of
the things that can give us hope for a
revival of a mass anti-war movement like
we saw in 2003 because there has been so
much that's D legitimized the system in
the view of many tens of millions of
people I think especially young people
who you know have grown up in a period
where war was normalized I mean for the
vast majority of my life the United
States has been occupying Afghanistan
and so you know we saw the the Occupy
Wall Street movement you know the the
uprising in Ferguson and the the rise of
the BDS movement I think that's another
important example because even though
the media the mainstream media is
completely pro-israel anti Palestinian
we still see the explosion of the BDS
movement all around the country and the
explosion of students for justice and
Palestine groups and other organizations
on college campuses so it can be done
the corporate media's power is not
omnipotent maybe a give us the mantra
from code pink when I'm a great admirer
of your organization on foreign policy
I'd like to point that out on foreign
policy Telegraph to our audience here
what they should do to D legitimize
forever war endless war go ahead in DC
to understand that this vast military
industrial security
a complex that's been built up since the
1960s has overwhelmed our budget taking
money away that must be used now for
things like a green new deal Medicare
for all free college education for young
people and it would make us more secure
by closing down the eight hundred plus
military bases we have our overseas
slashing hundreds of billions of dollars
from the Pentagon budget and investing
it in real human needs and the survival
of our planet ok well the the last two
items I would sign up to for sure ok
because we do have differences but when
it comes to ending forever war I'm on
your side all the way I would even wear
pink for you ok that's all the time we
have many thanks to my guests in
Washington and in Romania and thanks to
our viewers for watching us here at RT
see you next time and remember crosstalk
[Music]